but we're going to begin with the
breaking news from Ukraine this morning
Russia has launched its deadliest air
attacks in nearly two months the Russian
military fired a barrage of cruise
missiles and drones against cities
across Ukraine killing at least 16
people now the these attacks come amid
signs that Ukraine is preparing to
launch a major counter-offensives
sometime this spring Charlie dagada has
more on this story from Ukraine Charlie
good morning we are also ready for this
to be over
yep good morning to you Gail we are in
the city of nicopol across the river
from the zapparito nuclear power plant
this city came under attack last night
we're in April last night that City came
under attack last night and it comes as
Ukraine's defense minister makes this
announcement just today preparations for
the counter-offensive are being wrapped
up as soon as there is God's will the
weather and the decision by commanders
will do it
death and destruction overnight hundreds
of miles from any active front line a
cruise missile tore into this apartment
building in the Central City of uman
we're covered in bloodwells a young
mother the children were sleeping here
it's good that everyone's alive as she
shows the burning crater outside she
swears at the Russians responsible such
is the terrifying reality of life in
Ukraine that nowhere can be completely
safe while Russian missiles
indiscriminately rained down on its
cities killing civilians in their sleep
a number of young children are among the
dead in a wave of pre-dawn attacks
across the country
the capital Kiev came under attack too
for the first time in weeks with
officials saying air defenses shot down
11 missiles and two drones each civilian
victim constitutes a potential War crime
says the U.N head of human rights in
Ukraine if you look at the scale of the
injuries of the killings of the of the
destruction it's very clear that
International humanitarian law the the
rules of of War have been broken and
that war crimes have taken place
now we've spoken to senior Ukrainian
defense officials about that
counter-offensive they're obviously not
giving anything away it could happen
anywhere and any time along a border
that stretches for hundreds of miles
Gail
thank you Charlie jacket a reporting
from Ukraine